[Music]
we as humans have always used dogs to
help us get what we want and what we
need we make amazing teams because we've
evolved together and they make a massive
difference in conservation by finding
things that we couldn't possibly find to
give us information to help save species
our dog is to use their sense of smell
to find everything from endangered
species to invasive species and wildlife
crime which is something we're really
proud of come on guys I am Megan Parker
I'm research director and co-founder of
working dogs for conservation we're an
organization that finds dogs from rescue
situations shelters or career change
dogs we train them as detection dogs for
conservation projects around the world
right now we're on the way from the
kennel to the I want you to pick up
and the leopard skin and a Pinkman to
Train immediately
that might be finding scats of
endangered-species doing a population
estimate finding live animals that are
endangered that are very rare helping
fight well that crime in Africa by
having dogs fine ivory and rhino when
bush meat and guns and ammunition that
are used for poaching they can detect
microscopic larvae in water they can
detect one species of fish in a moving
stream that needs to be removed from the
ecosystem before it harms more animals
or plants you could imagine like well we
could build a computer that would sense
odors or a sense particles of some
object in the environment except we
can't build anything that bind like dogs
are actually the best technology and the
best able to detect something and then
tell their handler what they know
[Music]
I started out as a kid training dogs
when I was 10 and I just kept that
interest I became a biologist and I got
my PhD studying African Wild Dogs this
has been like a theme I guess for me in
my life I do have dogs myself I I've
actually lived with three dogs two of
them are working dogs one is retiring
he's on the couch
I'm guessing oh they're both on the
couch this morning we started to Leon an
endangered bat that she'll be working on
it's really simple at first she smells
the bat she sits and gets her toy it's
good work
yes good girl so and then we moved to
really complicated scenarios where the
dogs learned to find the scent of an
endangered animal and a very hard to
find place most of our dogs come from
shelters and were from a situation where
somebody can't keep a dog like this we
look at anywhere from one to two
thousand dogs before we find a dog that
makes our standards and can make it to
the field as a working dog for
conservation is there anything
particular you want to work
these dogs have really high energy they
want to play with a toy and without a
job their energy gets misdirected into
like tearing up your couch or killing
the cat or jumping through a window or
chasing whatever so these dogs are
really hard to have as pets when they
have a job and have a great home it's an
awesome combination a lot of the dogs
that I've personally trained I thought
it would be really hard at for us to
have them live in another continent but
the care and then look the bonds that
they have formed with their Scouts and
how hard they work in the kind of work
that they do when I see them they're
working there it's an awesome life for
them our work is important it pairs
these two things I care a lot about
which is taking dogs that are on death
row and then they get amplify all this
conservation that we care about that we
want to do the dogs are making the world
a better place they really are making
wildlife safer in places where they work
you